avec pascal droux président de
l'association france amérique latine
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur
arte france est ce que vous avez été
surpris par les résultats de ce premier
tour la présidentielle qu'est ce qu'ils
révèlent selon vous ces résultats
ces résultats étaient en fait attendu y
révèle une situation au chili totalement
pour la risée et qui est la conséquence
de la crise que traverse le pays crise
sanitaire notamment crise sociale très
forte que traverse le pays depuis
2010 9 donc c'est vrai que nous sommes
avec deux candidats deux générations
différentes
deux schémas de société totalement
antagonistes d'un côté josé antonio
caste qui est arrivé en tête avec près
de 28%
27,95 de l'autre gabriel
boric qui était un leader du mouvement
étudiant à partir de 2011 et qui depuis
est devenu député et représente
la gauche qui n'est pas la gauche
radicale d'ailleurs mais la gauche au
chili deux schémas de société ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire d'un côté l'état
providence c'est ce que prône gabriel
boric dans la continuité des mouvements
de ces deux dernières années et de
l'autre josé antonio caste qui lui reste
sur des fondamentaux extrêmement
libéraux mais qui est également connue
c'est pas la première fois que josé
antonio cast est candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il avait été en 2017 il
avait remporté près de 8% et cette fois
ci la crise la perte de repères la
désillusion des chiens conduit à ce
schéma vous l'avais dit dans votre
reportage inédit et totalement pour la
risée de candidats hors des partis
traditionnels c'est la première fois
aussi on le rappelle première fois en
trente ans que les candidats du centre
gauche et du centre droit sont absents
du second tour le candidat d'ultra
droite jose
antonio caste revendique ses affinités
avec la dictature pinochet ce qu'il ya
un paradoxe 78 % des électeurs ont voté
lors du référendum en octobre 2001 en
faveur d'une nouvelle constitution pour
tourner la page de l'ère pinochet
majoritairement ils ont donc voté hier
en faveur d'un candidat qui lui semblent
proches comment est-ce que vous
l'expliquer oui
en fait le chili est à la croisée des
chemins et cherche tout simplement
quelle peut être sa voie pour l'avenir
alors c'est vrai que ces dernières
années les manifestations les tensions
sociales la crise économique qui est né
mais également la problématique
sanitaire a tout simplement conduit à
une forme de crispation pour les uns il
était désormais possible de conduire
cette réforme constitutionnelle a engagé
le chili sur la voie de réformes
notamment sociales un des points
d'ailleurs pendant la campagne de
cristallisation a été le sujet des
retraites
josé antonio caste voulant maintenir le
régime de retraite par capitalisation ce
qui n'est pas le cas de gabriel boric
mais c'est vrai que ces tensions ces
manifestations la violence qui a pu
avoir ces dernières années a d'une part
inquiété une part de la population qui
peut-être conservatrice et d'autre part
donné l'idée de le sentiment qu'il était
enfin possible par ailleurs de changer
une société qui là aussi vous l'avez
rappelé était habitué à une forme de duo
paul politique depuis les années 90
entre le parti socialiste et la
démocratie chrétienne qui faisait
entente et qui ont pu gouverner pendant
plusieurs mandats depuis les années 90
et de l'autre une droite qui a été
portée ces dernières années par
sebastian pinera dont qui est le
président sortant et dont finalement la
polarisation aujourd'hui électorale marc
inde et de ses échecs et face à josé
antonio caste donc pour le second tour
de cette présidentielle au chili gabriel
boric 35 ans qu'elle est le pilier de
son programme
c'est véritablement
prenez l'état providence
il s'appuie mot reach d'abord il né en
1986 c'est donc une autre génération par
rapport à l'euro c'est antonio caste qui
lui est né en 1966
boric c'est aînés des mouvements
étudiants qui sont apparus dans les
années 2010 il est apparu en 2011 il
s'est engagé en politique il a été
député depuis 2014 et il prône vraiment
le l'état providence la réforme
constitutionnelle en effet la réforme du
système social et cet état providence
qui est un des points là aussi de débat
majeur aujourd'hui de l'élection
présidentielle
c'est vraiment la ligne essentiel de
boric qui a fait alliance avec le parti
communiste sans pour autant se
revendiquer de la gauche radicale
rien n'est joué pour le second tour ça
va être serré à quoi est-ce que vous
vous attendez pour cet entre-deux tours
par définition il s'agit d'une élection
le chacun des deux candidats est proche
l'un de l'autre un près de 28% pour l'un
près de 26 pour l'autre 27 95 25 71
réel est écrit ce qui est certain c'est
ce que cette polarisation va amener à
des difficultés politiques que l'année
prochaine
il et 2022 c'est le référendum sur une
nouvelle constitution sur une nouvelle
assemblée est donc forcément avec un
président quels qu'ils soient qui devra
manoeuvrer négocier avec une assemblée
qui ne sera de toute façon pas sur la
ligne fixée par chacun des deux
candidats merci beaucoup pour votre
regard pascal droux je rappelle que vous
êtes président de l'association france
amérique latine